hello this is definition and yes I have
absolutely no idea which baseball team
is on the hat that I wear Cheers
in my never-ending quest to collect junk
I decided to get another one of these
boxes this time it's the Superman DC
legion of collectors one so let's unbox
it and see what it's in as you can see I
love a bloody long Superman open it up I
can see the patches out it's been opened
patches there they can go on the wall I
collect all these [ __ ] on my wall you
see so quite happy with that
put a nerdgasm in over here you see
lights because it's a combination of
supermen and supermen the Funko pop so
really happy with that t-shirt
absolutely love that next is a little
Superman keyring I've got a Batman one
of me keys so quite happy with that got
a limited edition Superman Funko pop I'm
quite happy with that one I've got other
Superman Funko pops you can see them
over there I don't even want to look at
them anymore because I've got this piece
of junk instead this is the favorite
thing I've ever really liked this one
we've got an Action Comics that can go
me more as well Harley Quinn in that and
Ted Joker was I've got a Superman number
one Barry and comic which yeah I'm quite
happy with I collect a lot of fun ghosts
and so yeah quite happy with that it's
very fungal theme this week so loads of
cool little things if you're 15 years
old to be honest I think even a 15 year
old wouldn't collect these things but I
enjoy them thanks very much for checking
out my unboxing review there'll be
another one coming soon so take care